but the jump is definitely look i'm in
i'm in on a couple coins you know i'm in
on some uh
tron i'll be honest i'm in on a little
bit of nano and a little bit of algorand
bro i'll be honest with you
you know i want i'm in on some etc and
some eth bro i went deep
so yeah i'll admit that i'm [ __ ] mild
i'm exposed
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
what's up daddy yo what's up play boys
huh
look at the got snow out there huh
yeah i see you got that little sugar
pineapple there with y'all
yeah sugar pineapple dog now are you
doing
the podcast from a restoration hardware
or where's your new studio at
is that the inside of a u-haul truck
budget cut yeah guys we had to pull over
actually because the engine volume was
uh really
buddy so yeah it definitely smells like
definitely some really good wood uh
thinner or something in here wood
thinner yeah whatever the wood shop is
yeah remember wood shop oh i love wood
the best
and your your teacher always was missing
a finger like no matter what school you
went to they're already missing a few
fingers
yeah there was always injury and it was
like always yeah it was always like the
drug dealer kids were like building like
a um
like a bird house and they would like
cry at the end of the year and [ __ ]
but they were always really good at it
like damn man how is druggie dave so
good at this
he had a real knack for it and they
would write like xanax on the windows of
it and [ __ ] like they were always kind
of taking it to like a weird level for
the birds yeah by they i mean
theo van is a kid
you get a seven story bird house who
knows baby who knows
how how's it going out there mr vaughn
how's that how's that snow that's what
you get for leaving us man
enjoy that [ __ ] ice cold weather bud
dude well hey i'm glad you made it
through the moguls of that sentence
um i like how he abruptly ended with bud
i bud hey double down on bro again so i
changed too much he should have just
went i'm not a words bud
bud he should
he should be able to press a button when
he knows he's not gonna get to the end
of a session
um hey where do you guys get the rest of
the wood for the back
it's kind of distracting yeah man black
curtain doesn't mean anything
that just means there's a kitchen behind
yeah you look like a shitty youtube
magician
are there people dish are people washing
dishes behind you theo
yeah they are yeah they are hey guys we
need more ramekins
[Laughter]
dude why is every kitchen always out of
ramekins there's always one dude
like he's always like a gay guy like we
don't have any ramekins
every time you get a [ __ ] for the studio
then it's good we're gonna have to
change it next week
he's laughing but it hurts yeah he's
laughing but he's going to take it on
nick's
face after the show theo hits his
employees
oh that's great we're just virtually and
it's obviously your vr 70s show again
[Music]
it's it's snowed here man it's snowed
big time over here
oh and now you're a little you're a
little swamp lizard so you're not used
to the snow i was born in the snow
yeah i wasn't i was not born in it man i
don't i mean i believe in it but i just
don't
like it that much i guess it's kind of
shocking a lot of how much snow we're
talking how much snow we talking like
real snow or is it just like a little
you know
maybe four inches yeah you ever look at
postcards during the holidays and it's
like that one postcard that's just
covered in snow
yeah that's nashville yeah that's
[ __ ] natural yeah
that's how they're acting right yeah
theo called me yesterday like dude we're
sledding down capitol hill
we got a canoe oh god dude gross no
yeah it's like when i call my dad and
tell us about the weather in college
yeah man yeah cool no one gives a
vehicle what else you got
i got shorts on i'm glad you went ice
fishing but i'm wearing shorts wearing
shorts and i can't eat in restaurants
are you wearing no-show socks i am
shorts are good except for church bro
that's where i draw the line son
you might as well come out the closet if
you're wearing shorts to church praise
god
all praise god man i was saying i don't
know how much longer we have joe coy on
these shows man he's doing movies with
steven spielberg
and just blowing up man i said we got
him for about another week
are you really joking yeah we got to see
how the movie does but uh
no no no but you know no i i i take that
back universe
uh no the movie's gonna do great it's
gonna crush yeah it's gonna crush
man uh it's forest gump too yeah
yeah it's a prequel it's uh it's a
rainforest
it's a pretty cool yeah it's down as
actually yeah yeah of course yeah yeah
yeah
is it rainforest gump yeah yeah it's
guys it's jungle gump yeah it's jungle
gump man
well rain forest gump was better than
jungle gump no i don't think so
you guys kind of already kicked it off
but uh we brought back some of our
favorite uh
listener rose from the youtube comments
and joe coy's got a list uh
to roast both you guys oh should i read
them now
yeah why don't you read a couple okay
cool it says uh i got one from
squirrelbong
which is already good he said brendan
seems like he would wait in line
all day to try the new size of hot dog
[Laughter]
i guess is that to eat
to try a new size of hot oh i gotcha
yeah now you got it he's a connoisseur
he's a connoisseur he's a cover story
yeah
he's all right
sounds like he's doing good that one's
good exactly um this is from
adam brown i'm sorry brandon it's about
you again
uh switch them up what you want okay uh
well let's do this one since i said it's
about brendan already
hey man uh brendan's mustache
looks like a bar code that'll never scan
that's good oh this ain't coming up sir
oh
this ain't coming up sir that's okay
check out bad boy you got going on your
lip but
sail decline homie you scan
you scan brendan's mustache and it comes
up lube what
i don't want lube uh theo oh wait this
is from
this is from mr painkiller 616.
she says mr payne i don't want to follow
any of these guys
just by their names theo looks like he
shops from bass
pro shops wait did i say that right yeah
i read that right
he said theo looks like he shops from
bass pro
shops for a living
that's funny oh he's a personal shopper
at bass pro shops
okay first of all you guys didn't read
it right man
come on guys no i swear to god shoplifts
shoplifting
oh no it's a shoplift yeah still looks
like he's in a shop
hey first of all don't make me look like
an [ __ ]
it says shop someone spelled it from
all right the oh so uh your producer
[ __ ] this one up
another black guy for nick
[Laughter]
i'm gonna read what's on the paper and
i'm going to do it one more time theo
looks like he shops
from bass pro shops and you two can go
[ __ ] yourselves
it'd be easier to deal with steals from
back i don't like the fact that phil's
inside of a u-haul truck and he's trying
to correct me
yeah read it right [ __ ]
dude this is an 18-footer dude okay
watch your mouth
how dare you say 18 foot or so
uh all right where are we at now uh this
is from dr
drinny is that drinny uh let's
who cares who gives a [ __ ] right brendan
looks like he makes eye contact while
eating popsicles
i can see yeah yeah he gets all the way
down to the wood part yeah look you're
right
right deep throat one of those
oh he's a lot of times he gets splinters
in his butthole when he's eating them
yeah brandon likes to put the popsicle
in his [ __ ] after he's done eating
the cold part
[Laughter]
let me just put that warm stick in there
uh here's a here's one from i
pokey eyes out oh i read it like the pop
pop
i read it like pokey like tuna yeah
that's fine that's just you know that
that's something
i like pokey yeah i thought that's where
they were going with this but is i
poke eyes out all right you ready damn
feel looks like he smells gas before
filling up
yeah i know i do look at him there
i i really do that yeah yeah i really do
oh my god that's good what is that 87.
oh that's that 87.
that's my audition tape for the wire
right there i don't know if you guys can
see that image right there or not
jason hollander you ready for this one
theo looks like he gets paid in
crossbows
[Laughter]
i think tate i think he likes that one
actually he's not even laughing
yeah um mr painkiller 616 again
painkiller hey he's on a roll uh brendan
looks like he had uh
uh oh okay i'm sorry brendan looks like
he had an epiphany from
some 41 song a some 41 song i'm sorry i
don't know who some 41 is yeah that's
horrible that would have been better if
i i knew who that was
i kind of get it he looks like he had
epiphany from a some 41 song that's
where he's getting his inspiration from
some
punk rock he's got yellow on
oh it's gotcha it's an ant yeah
all right what's next uh do another theo
one the the sous chef one do you see
that one oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i like
this one this is from
james richmond theo looks like he uh
phil looks like a sous chef at a women's
prison that's funny
look at him there no more peas for you
brenda
[Laughter]
yeah i [ __ ] in the beans he looks like
the chef and the inmate
[Laughter]
uh bryce hamilton theo looks like a
taxidermist intern
[Music]
that's funny with the hamster shirt on
ah love it am i just reading these bad
or what
no no no okay i feel like it's not your
fault okay
good okay no it's not your fault they're
not good
that's good for roast my host i think
it's better if we're all in studio
there's
a little delay when he's hearing him he
can't respond oh i thought they were
pretty pretty yeah not bad no i think
they're great man
that was great yeah i miss you theo
i miss you too man i want to know more
about the film when's it coming out
may 3rd i shoot it i shoot it in
vancouver and daly city
it's amazing man are you looking for two
white guys in any capacity you're not
going to believe it that's all we're
looking for
yeah we're coming back i knew steven
spielberg yeah man
he said something about diversity yes
yes
what's your role going to be jokoy huh
what is your role going to be um i'm
lead it's uh
it's about uh easter sunday with my
family and it takes place
one day just complete chaos during that
whole day as you can see you wrote it
do you well i didn't write it it was my
it was my pitch it was my idea
and uh and ken chang helped me write it
so it's amazing
little like death at a funeral type type
vibe like a whole family
yeah it's just yeah exactly that's fun
who's this big baby what up brandon what
up theo it's your boy benny here all the
way from the uk
the sunny uk shores
[ __ ] state of this [ __ ] also
beautiful shire got a debate club for
you
now i know theo you ain't procreated
before and i think humanity thanks you
for that
brendan you've got two uh let's hope
they got their mom's intelligence eh
true so my debate club is
sunspeak daughters i mean you've got
that no quit a son
or that all hit a daughter so the debate
club is
some of your daughters gang gang
so cute so
cute congrats man dollars are different
yeah
do you do you have a daughter i don't
have a daughter yeah we we both have
sons
yes it's a little easier with sons
you're still scared of the world for
them
but with daughters you're talking about
a world of different way
fear factor and then you also think
about how you were as a guy
coming up you're like i don't want her
to meet anyone like me
correct so it's a scary i feel like it's
a scary world for women unless they're
in hollywood
yeah i think sons is dangerous bro
because sons got that danger dick on
them
yeah and a dick is full of danger bro if
you think about it yeah 100 hands down
you never see this weapon ever oh you
don't ever hear somebody oh yeah
larry did something awesome with his
dick the other day for someone no
never i mean the the previous guy just
jerked off on his phone
and called us yeah he called us yeah
yeah
i mean you should have whether you
should have a license to carry your
penis
you know if you have a gun a loaded gun
you need a license penis you need a
license there's a lot of people walking
around with loaded penises
that are very dangerous with their penis
yeah you unbelievable you got to be
careful the penis you never make smart
choices
never penis doing the thinking you
should never say this to a girl
you sure you're on birth control yeah
yeah
and that's when it happened yeah a penis
man you got to think about that man
a little daughters are friendlier
they're sweeter little kids don't give a
[ __ ]
bro they will kill you they'll kill your
wife yeah they'll burn your crib down
they don't give a [ __ ] they would sell
crack if they could if they knew how to
do business
yeah that's true um yeah you're right
little boys are violent dude
violent they are men and they're mean
and then also
thank god for google because your kids i
don't know how your kids were my kids
my son asked me the random [ __ ] that i
have no clue about
yes like that how long does it take to
get to mars what the [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i have to look it up
600 days that's very true by the way
my dad made up so many [ __ ] things
when you think about oh he lied so many
[ __ ] times
[ __ ] bro a lot of [ __ ] man lied about
everything yes but would you rather your
dad lie
or tell you or like have to go look up
the answer like some lame ass dad dude i
would rather my dad [ __ ] lie to me on
the spot
at least my dad knows what's up yeah i
know no because the problem is my dad
would
lie then i'd go back to school and he's
tell the lie and the kid's like no
you're dead full of [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's a [ __ ]
now my kids can go back to school and
drop facts on those little bastards yeah
but then people are gonna be like oh
your dad just googled it at least my dad
really sold it
yeah yeah and my dad smoked but when
when he was living with me he used to
smile
you really sold it like chainsmoker what
did he say he was a chainsmoker
so he really sold it like everything he
said just looked real because he was
he would take a that's very nice long
drag at the end of it yeah
dude do you lie to your kid ever always
i've yet to tell my son the truth about
anything yeah
you know why you know why boys are
resilient
you know why they're they're crazier
yeah they
because they never break anything yet
until they break something that's when
they said that's when they
chill does your son break anything he
broke his arm
he slowed down after that but i mean
before that he was
diving and jumping and i'm i'm on this
diet and my my son wanted me to eat this
candy i'm like dad can't have that and
he's like oh
and my you know he just gets it from his
mom he goes oh cuz you want a six-pack
and like
you had like a six-pack and he grabs my
stomach's you have a pack now
all right dude keep talking [ __ ] fat
patrick boy
should we move on some relationship
advice yeah
these people yeah i'm sure we can help
someone look at us
look at us what's up king in the scene
listen i love what you guys do
uh i need you guys during this whole
pandemy thing things just this is crazy
i watch all of you guys this podcast
right now i've been watching you since
2014
and while watching the ufc as well so um
can you understand it or relationship
advice i've been with the girl for two
years
we just got married and her parents have
a bunch of property
so we're gonna move into the property
but in two two different houses
you know her parents are gonna live in
one house we're gonna live in hours and
um
so what do you think can you understand
it you know by the way i'm really close
with her dad
and her mom so um we'll see how he goes
do you think it's going to be kind of
weird do you think it's kind of like not
really appropriate
um what do you guys think i don't think
it's that big of a deal i'd like to see
the real estate i'd like to see the
houses but if you're close with like i'm
really close with my mother-in-law
father-in-law
they live like a block from it's nice
having them around man yeah
full-time babysitter sometimes you want
to go on a little date night
you need a break come over help out with
the kids yeah they're right on the
property i think it's a tight move when
you make it work
yeah you can just send your baby to the
babysitter just walk across
go to that house right there mommy and
daddy here it's mommy and daddy time
yeah that's perfect
yeah i agree with you on that one yeah
um what i don't agree with is he has the
same curtain as theo
that's behind him no one should have
black curtains in their house
but i feel for this guy he's very
sincere
it is a hard time right now the pandemic
has put him in a situation
uh but i don't want him to think that
going to the parents house
is a bad thing it's actually a good
thing if you get along with him
like if you don't well he gets along
with the dancers you don't get involved
in
if you don't get along with them it's
it'd be a nightmare oh it'll be an
absolute [ __ ]
yeah like could you live with your
parents
no not i can either not at all after two
days i'm like
you guys good not even across the street
it'd be tough oh it would suck
it would suck it would suck murder would
happen yeah
yeah and i don't want to do that um yeah
but you know during the pain well
obviously he's not you know this is
going to be a good move for him
smart bro smart move what do you think
deal
i think if you're young and like you're
19 or 20 then it's kind of a little bit
more stressful because
the parents are worried you guys are
over there doing sex and being naughty
and they're sneaking around
um but i think if you're older more of
an adult that kind of stuff's all gone
out the window so you know you just have
to be a decent man
and you're getting free house this guy
sounds like he's getting free house
from he didn't say he was paying for
nothing this dude you know
he's just got to spend time with the
daughter shake the dad's hand every now
and then
[ __ ] try to time when he goes out to
the mailbox so he ain't out there at the
same time as them that kind of [ __ ]
you know not get caught up in too much
verbal hang time you know but
i think uh i think it's a good move man
and yeah they have babysitters then you
have a babysitter right there
i think families need to stick together
if you can afford to have them on the
same property
it's not a bad idea you could always do
a little electric fence as well
that's not a bad movie a little electric
fence a little you know
yeah yeah get a badass guard dog but you
know you can't come over here unless
he's inside man yeah
just keep your distance yeah yeah i like
that
yeah just say keep telling them say
muffins in heat say muffin is in heat
you can't come over
[Laughter]
sounds like you have himself a little
six-figure queen over there
yeah yeah he has a good setup yeah he
married into money good job tight move
dude you won the lottery
listen man your thick friend here is on
a diet i'm cutting down from 272. that's
right i'm big and i got the help of
athletic greens today's program is
brought to you by athletic greens the
most comprehensive daily nutritional
beverage i've ever had
all right one tasty scoop athletic
greens contain 75 vitamins minerals
whole foods source ingredients including
a multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more that all
work together
to fill in your nutritional gaps if
you're on a diet it's impossible to get
all that
with just food all right and they love
to make sure
you guys are digging it and right now
athletic greens is doubling down on
supporting your immune system
during the winter months because we know
it gets crazy they're offering you guys
a free one-year supply of vitamin d get
that d in your body man
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase
if you visit the link today all right
simply visit athleticgreens.com kats
join the health experts athletes
podcasters comedians
health conscious go-getters around the
world who make a daily commitment to
their health
again visit athleticgreens.com cats
get your free year supply of vitamin d
get that d
in your mouth and five free travel packs
if you're selling online man you got to
do it the right way and thank god for
ship
station no matter how much you sell
shipstation makes it super easy to
manage and ship
all your orders from all your sales
cheaper
faster more efficiently you can ship
with any carrier we got you covered
they have discounted shipping rates you
spend a lot less time on shipping a lot
more time growing your business
that's what it's all about no matter
where you're selling amazon
etsy your own website like your boy here
shipstation funnels all your orders in
one simple interface
so you can manage it from anywhere even
your freaking cell phone
all right with shipstation small
business can now access the same rates
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies without any contracts or
commitments
it's no wonder shipstation has more
five-star reviews than any other
shipping software
ship more in less time just use the code
k-ats to get a 60-day free trial
try it out for 60 days man that's two
months free of no hassle stress free
shipping
just go to shipstation.com click on the
microphone
top of the homepage type in kats that's
shipstation.com enter the code cats make
ship happen yeah all right this guy's
got another question he also has the
nose piercing
what's up guys uh this is eddie and this
is iris
on some relationship advice don't put
our names in it
um that's not a real name that's not a
real name
shut up
this relationship is going to last a
very long time anyway
yeah you got to get out of this life
whoever takes out who
on the date so say if i take out her on
a date should i drive or should she
drive
she takes me out on age should she drive
or should i drive to
the date so king understand it thank you
theo
and thank you brandon theo for being uh
funny
and making her laugh and brennan for
being good looking and
making her what while oh my god wow
thank you yeah oh so i'm not handsome
thank you thanks eddie
yeah thanks eddie i'll just be the ugly
guy
yeah they basically ugly
um yeah this relationship's going
nowhere yeah
i don't mind if the chica drives man i
don't have a control problem so she
if she has a dope ride yes it's great
yeah i
like it when the chicks drive to be
honest yeah i don't mind it yeah i don't
mind it a big deal
yeah would you would you mind if they
paid for dinner
no please pay for dinner pay and drive
yeah oh and by the way oh [ __ ] me later
yeah yeah
also open my door [ __ ] yeah yeah let me
decide if we're having sex
how's that yeah yeah that'd be fun
that'd be cool
deal you got a problem if if one of your
uh women
pick you up and you gotta go well for me
it for me it makes me agitated because
the women drive you know real you can't
really
like unless it's danica patrick then all
these other [ __ ] drive
real questionably yeah that's fair so
it's a lot of being patient when you're
driving with them
you know and i like to sit on the gas i
like to go for it i like to take a
chance at dying every time i get on an
expressway
and a lot of these ladies yeah i'm
thanking yourself
and a lot of these ladies aren't like
that they want to look around they'll
get to a stop sign and look around and
[ __ ] i'm like what are we
doing you know you know that you're so
right about that because uh i do like to
uh risk it all um so when
she's driving and we're at a red left
arrow
and there's no [ __ ] cars around go go
just [ __ ] go but then it's a fight
it's scary i can't believe you're asking
me to do that [ __ ]
go it's a red left no one's here
i'm hungry that's why you got to make
him take ways because ways to force you
to
stress you out yeah makes you take the
shortcuts
people yeah no man i don't think rebel
when i take the red left i
go i go hard real hard i go i
i go if i don't care if stop lights are
red or green i go if there's no one
around and i can go
if there is someone if there's no police
around i go i go
and i keep going until i get where i
want i run lights all the time
all the time don't understand that yeah
if i'm at the airport like four in the
morning there's nobody on the road i do
not wait for
life none of the lights they don't even
exist in my world
nope yeah people always ask me how did
you get here so fast
there were no lights no lights man not
one [ __ ] light
same same
but yeah i think it also if you take in
somebody on a date
what about this what do you guys do
about picking the movie are you guys
willing to go to a movie that your lady
wants to go to or will you guys say
or will you guys say no be honest with
me i say no
yeah i i don't say no but i i make it
very uncomfortable
i got something you should watch with
your girlfriends
yeah or i like to laugh or say i like to
say that a lot i like to laugh
yeah let's watch something on me you
like stupid [ __ ] like that yeah
just low-key yeah like really wow pretty
stupid yeah
all right i'll watch it though and the
whole time like
yeah dumb yeah
all right so moving on one more
relationship advice question
what's going on theo what's going on
brandon i got some relationship advice i
need
you know my girlfriends my first really
serious relationship
she got me don't touch me but keep
touching me hoodie for my birthday
literally everything i asked for awesome
birthday sash
you know birthday girls wearing it on
the slopes took me to holiday valley for
the weekend
wow and you know every time i hang out
with her it's just
i learned something new about her we
laugh every time we hang out
she's just like my best friend you know
we've been dating for about six months
now i've known her for a while though
and i just i i don't know when it's time
to say i love you i feel like
i feel like i feel it i know she's kind
of she said it a couple times
just like kind of slipped it in there
with some stuff
i just it's my first relationship so i
don't really know you know
when i need to put it out there cause i
definitely feel that
i she sees me looking at her you know
with my smile
all grainy she knows i'm thinking it's
camera
but like this dude's getting wet first
relationships
you drop the l bomb bubba yeah i'll be
like hiroshima on that girl
let's do this man test the waters out um
here's another thing we know you're in
love you're wearing a [ __ ]
shash you spent six minutes how in love
you are yeah
uh first of all it's six months um ask
us this question in a year
yeah it's gonna be different uh actually
it's gonna be a different phone call
like hey i hate this [ __ ] yeah
relationship advice how do i break up
with my girl yeah
no you're obviously in love it also
sounds like this is the first time
you've ever been puppy
yeah drop the l bomb though people think
too serious with the
yeah i don't i throw it around i throw
it around too
i told my [ __ ] uh postmates love you
man
yeah man drop the food off i said love
you to everyone i love saying love you
to somebody and they cringe like
okay like they don't respond like did
anyone hug you
yep i say love you like hello
yeah i throw it around pretty loose i
like to say i love you after i pay at
those uh
places off the new jersey turnpike you
got to put that money to the man or
whatever i say i love you right there
point blank
if it's man or woman you know theo is a
love guy
yeah theo says love you a lot man thank
you bro
you do he does thank you depends what
day you catch them in the week but yeah
ah he always says love you man to me
you catch them updates yeah different
people get different reactions
um but i will say this man yeah
dude this dude man if you do any more
stuff with this lady she going to leave
you because you're going to be with a
man bro
you got to tighten up you're already
wearing yeah you're going to make you
got to do something dude you wearing the
electrical
[ __ ] onesie you got on right there
you got to tighten up dude
you know but here's the thing a lot of
times guys will
once a girl says it then a guy will just
say it back without even thinking about
it
yeah then you're stuck in a relationship
for two years wondering if you really do
you realize you don't
and then you leave you know people put
too much power in the word though
it's all right to throw it out there
yeah nick chin you tell your girls you
love them
yeah i kind of like uh
i mean that's a no from china no i've
done it before but not like we don't we
don't say it often
it's always
i say wild [ __ ] when i'm buzzed i say it
he doesn't say it he
oh i say it all the time you gotta say
it man let her know jen
no she's a cold-hearted [ __ ] killer
man yep
did your parents say it to you oh i have
so much love in my family huh yeah
but yeah i know i know you have a lot of
love but do they tell you they love you
yeah but joe doesn't know that i was
friends with my girlfriend for
like over 20 years before we started
dating so it's a weird thing
we said we'd love each other before but
now it's like in love it's kind of a
it's a tough one yeah but i am
definitely i love her yeah it doesn't
sound like you're in love
but we'll figure that out another day
yeah i don't know if i would ensure this
question for him like it's a tough
position it's not though
throw it out there dude don't put so
much power in the word it's not a big
deal yeah yeah chen that sounds
unreliable it sounds like the
i if i were an insurance agent i don't
know if i would give coverage
on that love policy of yours you
wouldn't invest in his love stock you're
saying
i just think it would be a really high
premium it sounds
uncertain it sounds like the windows
aren't fully sealed off it sounds like
they could only have some maybe 12-year
shingling going on or something
yeah as opposed to something small
something larger uh something longer
time
i just don't know man i don't you think
he's insecure about something
and he's not telling us directly am i i
think he's japanese dude and they don't
[ __ ] say it
he's talking about what are you talking
about chin again what yeah
yeah he said yeah thank you
i'm gonna be honest do they don't say
they never say anything and then they
[ __ ] jump off
a building or express themselves in
crazy sex art or something
you know what i'm saying that's crazy
japanese yeah he's right
let's be honest we're gonna talk
tomatoes let's talk tomatoes bro
yup i love it man all right uh
yeah you guys want to play the name game
oh my boy
get it this will be good jelly roll
aha guess who's back
what's up bubba's i figured we'd do a
thing today called the name
game in honor of president's day i want
you both to list the name of every
president you can name or think of
can't wait to hear this one
[Laughter]
man and uh so this time we're actually
going to put a timer on it chin's got it
should we do
10 seconds we're uh you three are going
around the room theo brandon and joe
trying to name it okay
so what what did we do what one one
president each or we just offered just
one president
oh yeah yeah one you go i'll go theo
goes okay so we start now go ahead
abraham lincoln george washington easy
one easy one
um i'm gonna go with grover cleveland
hard one
wow yeah he definitely looked this up
before jfk
he didn't have it stop ten seconds
oh no no ten seconds for each person oh
so just like once
once someone hits it so keep going how
would you ever think that it's 10
seconds for the whole game the worst
game
ever he should also enjoy everything
all the presents in 10 seconds how would
you
ever think it's 10 seconds for the whole
game
time time nope that's it they only got
three jen is great
like he played this game 40 times just
do it
he's playing the game
not bad chen you're right you're a good
guy you're a good guy
who's up me yeah he said jfk yeah uh
george washington
oh no i'm sorry you [ __ ] lost bush oh
no
i want to keep going bush george bush
yeah i was gonna say george bush what
but you didn't i got ten seconds though
but you see he's gonna say something say
say that
i got bush go theo all right dude i'll
say donald trump
oh that's a good one uh i'm gonna say uh
obama
nice i'll go with biden nice
i'll go with um gerald ford got it
carter nixon nice
all the reindeer fade on reindeer games
sorry that was a joke um i will go with
uh your boy uh
10 seconds would you say stephen douglas
it's d stephen douglas did you just say
one of the douglasses from kirk douglas
and michael
with his younger brother stephen hey is
steven douglas a president douglas
i'm gonna go there i'm gonna go with uh
charlie sheen
stephen he was a president he was
stephen a douglas was
a senator no he wasn't
he was a president nick of the united
states are you
i think so we'll keep reading his wiki i
i am yeah just senator top billing
senator stephen a douglas he looks
presidential
deal lost or me and i don't know keep
going or do we just
count yeah cheaters yeah you guys can
keep going if you can creeps
uh clinton uh biden nope you already
said that
joe you're winner i'd like to get uh
dude hoodie if i could we'll say
something
we're gonna send you a a stephen douglas
presidential shirt
please bro he is president of the south
that is true oh nice
which still does he was yeah that's fine
which is still
wrong pick someone from the confederacy
yeah that was weird man
look my confederacy is confederacy of
dunces that's my favorite one to support
and that's written by robert after
stephen jackson was gonna say colonel
mustard
you guys left uh george w bush on the
table that was an easy one but that's
pretty much all i could have gotten yeah
after that whenever these whenever the
pictures start turning black and white
that's when it gets a little dicey yeah
yeah all right that was a fun one though
thanks jelly
roll thanks jelly roll um
i'll say this man isn't it weird how
like the people that remember you
even those people like a legacy only
lasts like so long you know what i'm
saying
yeah it's crazy bro there's a shelf date
for everything
for the world everything keeps spinning
it's just moving on somebody dies you're
like oh my god how are we going to move
on yeah we move on
we do move on real fast we get back to
business yeah
but but even in entertainment it's like
stuff only has like
after like an another generation nobody
it's it's gone kind of it's done
it's like you know when i have to
explain to my son who beau jackson was
like he sees it in documentaries but
he's like there's no to me i'm like
that was superman do you not understand
that well it's the same
with like the lebron jordan it's good
that that
the last dance doc came out young kids
could see it like oh jordan was dope
it's like yeah man that's where the
argument comes from
he's a clown my hound for us look clean
on this home boys first of all
it's a real him not all these [ __ ]
dogs you got on here
pugs and [ __ ] snickerdoodles and [ __ ]
this is a raccoon trained dog second of
all oh
it's a tax paying dog he's winning some
money pkc champion
ukc not a champion oh oh oh
pretty good one oh yeah and he does a
service to the community gets rid of all
them [ __ ]
little trash pandas running around
oh [ __ ] the [ __ ] yeah
is that satan no that's uh
that's iris that guy's girlfriend still
yelling in the back
don't say my name don't use our real
name not our real name just stupid
then he tried to pretend like it wasn't
the real names he's like those aren't
our real names
he tried to cover up he's like babe
those aren't our real things
i forgot about that oh my god hey why
would you need a dog to chase raccoons
away is it that big of a [ __ ] problem
i thought we love raccoons yeah i like a
good one i love raccoons got the cool
hands
i don't like this dog me neither more
raccoons
i love raccoons too they look like
little burglars yeah
man cute hands they got real hands yeah
real hands
yeah man they hold carrots and stuff
they hold i've seen one hold a coffee
mug yeah they go through your trash who
gives them yeah
[ __ ] it's trash that's why you threw it
away
[ __ ] your dog nah nah man this dog is
obviously he said it wants him award you
idiot
and what i'm going to say is this sorry
i was talking to brendan i mean and what
i'm going to say is this
also what that's nature was this nope
why do you want to kill a raccoon for
they're violent their mother nature's
[ __ ] homeless people dog
they're violent beasts they sneak in
your house at night they'll steal your
sugar they'll take your [ __ ] kid if
they could drag it off they don't give a
damn
i doubt that highly theo you're full of
[ __ ] look they walk
man more people they walk they stand on
their feet and walk
yeah they take away your like empty
trash good will clothing they're great
man
more people now from dogs yeah dude look
how cute that is look he just got
soap i guess oh sugar sugar i think look
at that
you want to kill that theo [ __ ] you
looks like a little bird
man bro they have hiv on their paws dude
they are
a lot no they go through a lot dude
there's videos of them using intravenous
drugs
there's videos of them uh doing sex
outside
there's one smoking crack in india
there's a lot of videos of these animals
on the internet doing not usually
thanksgiving bro i've seen that yeah you
seem to have skid row out there
i still have compassion
there are a lot of diseases too i mean
aren't all animals though outside they
all
carry some [ __ ] man yeah man these
homies are about that life fam these
[ __ ] are about that life you know
some people have a real fear of raccoons
i don't get it i don't get it
they're the cutest [ __ ] things in the
world they [ __ ] that dog yeah
yeah well i think as long as they let
them fight if
raccoons and animals should be able to
what i don't like is they go hide and
then they
they play this kind of like cat and
mouse game i would like to see them
really go at it almost like they do with
those
fist fights in the backyard those
backyard fights oh that'd be cool
yeah little paper panda fight league
yeah i like that
pay-per-view yeah but not much
okay cool not a dollar
you know we just got hit by a winter
storm out here and we're in the winter
and so if you want the winter baby they
got it mother nature is serving that
[ __ ] up
one icy spoon full at a time
so you got to take care of your yard
right now and i'm not talking about you
yard that's outside of your home talking
about that body yard baby hair body hair
and the lawn mower 3.0 trimmer is the
best hygiene tool for the modern
man treat you dick in your body
treat you different cracks and crevasses
treat them right
whack them out get the best tool for the
job
don't get cold feet this winter take
care of your body bust it out clean it
up get 20
off and free shipping by going to
manscape.com
king sting that's right 20 off
with free shipping by going to
manscape.com kingston the twenty percent
off free shipping by
going to manscape.com kingston thanks
manscape for making our winter
body look so good it's not quite that
time for march madness you know my lsu
men's basketball
uh fan and mildly an aficionado i would
say
if i'm gonna get real italian about it
and one of my favorite things to do is
watch them play ball
watching boys play and right now
america's top-rated sportsbook app is
giving all new players the chance to
cash 100
that's right new customers can bet one
dollar on any team to hit a
three-pointer in
any basketball game this week and if
your team makes it
you reign in 100 that's it it takes one
three-pointer being hit by your chosen
team
to turn one dollar into 100 sounds like
a no-brainer
this slam dunk of an offer won't be
around for long draftkings has paid out
over seven
billion dollars to its customers since
2012.
so they know a thing or two about big
paydays
download the draftkings sportsbook app
now and use promo code kats
to get your shot to turn one dollar into
100
when you bet on any team to hit a three
pointer in any basketball game this week
that's promo code kats for new customers
to get a shot
at 100 to one odds on any basketball
team to a three-pointer only a draftking
sportsbook
must be 21 years or older new jersey
indianapolis michigan
or va only new customers only
restrictions apply winning is paid out
in four
25 dollar free bets see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 1800
gambler in indiana or 1-809 with it
in va you know what i'm saying call
888-532-3500
move on to some kinder stance brandon
theo what's going
on culture corner shout out you guys as
well nick chin
love everyone there i got a king
understinger for you guys
so cryptocurrency we've seen it all over
the place
bitcoin a few years back blew up
everyone made a fortune except for me
uh now we got this dogecoin hitter this
meme hitter
so uh i want to know what you guys think
about cryptocurrency let me know
king and her sing it gang gang buzz buzz
i love it can i say something real quick
yeah please the oldest youngest face in
the world
yeah this guy is 46-17
yeah right like [ __ ] is this dude
he's got grandkids but he gets carted to
the movies
that is strange you're right 46 17
46 17 years old
[Laughter]
hey man i just want to you know i want
you guys to roast me i'm retiring from
27 years at the post office who is this
guy
that's a great point
i i don't know much about crypto i know
uh elon musk swears by it
it's weird to me when actors and [ __ ]
demand payment and crypto
dude just take the [ __ ] cash and buy
your own crypto well
it's that [ __ ] easy yeah i don't
understand crypto either yeah i don't
shop online i like dollars
uh i like to stack my dollars i like to
wrap my dollars
um i'm not and plus i don't want to get
i don't want i don't want to fall
into this internet style lifestyle
i want that to be a choice if i want to
buy something online i'll do it
but i want to be online completely my
my everything can people hack into it
yeah you know what i'm saying like yeah
if it's internet based i don't know
who's controlling this [ __ ] thing who
owns it
it's not a real bank and you know what
else i want to make fun of other
people's money
you know what i mean the american dollar
is so dope
when you go to other countries like what
the [ __ ] is this
yeah that's not a dollar yep but with
crypto everyone's got the same [ __ ]
so yeah that's a good point and you got
to remember your uh password too for
crypto like did you see that one
criminal got
caught and he had like 17 million but
they were trying to get his password and
he couldn't remember it
yeah the money just it's just it's
floating
it's an icloud yep i'm good with that
yeah it's kind of crazy man everybody
and this young fellas or sir
he said a while back that like it blew
up a few years ago
and everybody made money but him
everybody i i know lost three thousand
dollars
exactly everyone i know lost money yeah
i don't know anyone who's made bank up
not one and everyone keeps talking about
oh it's making so much money i'm like
no one hit it when it made that jump it
sounds like the trendy thing to say
yeah i'm saying yeah but the jump is
definitely look i'm in
i'm in on a couple coins you know i'm in
on some uh tron i'll be honest i'm in on
a little bit of nano and a little bit of
algorand bro i'll be
honest with you you know i want i'm in
on some etc and some eth but i went deep
so yeah i'll admit that i'm [ __ ] mild
i'm exposed
[Laughter]
but it's that it's definitely
fascinating but it's like if it all
disappeared tonight i would have no one
to call
no one to ask and also then here's the
crazy part
i don't even know if i would admit to
people that i've lost the money because
i'd be ashamed
yeah so then you have a ton of people
just ashamed that they threw their money
into a [ __ ]
wishing well that they don't even get to
sit on the side of and have a cigarette
yeah a digital wishing well yeah if your
money or you forget your password what's
customer service yeah that's they're
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do nothing i saw i have an iphone 8 that
i kept because i couldn't get the
password
yeah so just if i'm holding on to this
iphone 8
imagine if i have 25 000 worth of
cryptocurrency
it's just floating i still have hotmail
i still have yahoo
hell yeah let me tell you this let me
tell you this mind blower right here uh
yokoi yes uh brendan doesn't have a
youtube account
what yeah well i don't have a personal
one i have it for my youtube
shows yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy right is that
are you dumb i'm sorry it's crazy right
well no because
let's see what have that let's put that
on the
you're like reminding me of my dad when
uh cds came out he's like
never never that's just the fad
that's what my dad said cds
yeah i should probably do one yeah yeah
sorry it just blows on mine every day
when i'm like oh man
i'm like i wanna i don't know i just
want him to be in
like i it just blows my mind that blows
my mind
oh i met tate deal boston uh sent me uh
uh seasoned assist for you because you
keep leaving comments on the pictures of
them
he said starting to creep him out a
little bit cause he's fine as [ __ ] son
what do you want me to do comment that
he's an ugly child anytime i post my
my son boston who's one theo gets on
there like damn shody got back
bro he's beautiful she's that diamond in
the rough fam you know
i'm just saying man he asked me to tell
you to back off a little bit before he
gets authorities involved
what i say the other day was nice what i
put on there y'all taking my dime to the
bank and even if you look at a picture
on his face he's wondering what's going
on dog
you know what i'm saying even he's a
little concerned that these freaking
wild boys got him out on this trail you
know
by the way this isn't brandon's uh
instagram it's someone else's
yeah i post on someone else's
oh you missed a post on february 6 you
got to go comment on
oh no i got in there somewhere i got him
yeah he's deep he's probably one number
one
you usually show up top for me i was
pretty late maybe on it
that's correct you know i try not to
comment on everything i know she i know
you know
yeah because you'll get flagged yeah
they're they're they're a flagging child
predators now yeah on instagram
which look we didn't get to vote on that
but i'll do it i'll definitely i'll back
off a little man
i say stay consistent theo
tiger likes it but you know little ones
getting uh he's getting worried man
you know what i'm going to start chiming
in thank you boy
oh yeah you got to see this hottie dog
you got to see this hottie
what's up cats crew i got a king of
stinger for you guys
um that surgery hitter
that body repair so this is the elbow
um two plates two screws nine pins and a
six inch rod in the forearm
uh two plates that i don't recommend it
i don't like it
probably never going to happen again so
yeah the question
is can you understand it surgeries
sometimes they can help
sometimes they can be harmful throughout
the rest of your life
so let me know what you guys think uh
gang gang
bose bows does anyone have plates in
here
uh i have the worst accident ever what
was it
compound femur fracture broken tibula
amphibious how did you do it
motorcycle oh and my my bone stuck out
about
two inches oh it's probably like the
whole bone was sticking out
um you want to see it yeah yeah let me
show you
oh look disgusting yeah i want to see
that but i thought you had a picture of
the bone sticking out
pull it out let's see that [ __ ] daddy
while you add it huh oh
that looks like a shark bite that's
where the bone came damn
that's a tough spot to break damn oh wow
the worst how long ago was that oh man i
was 15.
oh worst accident ever so surgery
oh there's that's me oh my god before
and after the accident that's my sister
she got a little burger king out of the
deal yeah man
my sister was a g man she she moved out
of the house she was already moved out
at that point i think she was 17 or
something
wow and uh and she was working at uh
wendy's full-time but i didn't like
wendy's
and she kept bringing me and i kept
asking for burger king and she came
literally every other day and brought me
burger king how long are we in the
hospital
oh my god three months oh yeah i was
like forever
and now you have a metal rod in there no
they they they were able to save my life
you know i still remember my doctor's
name man dr wigman
wow he was a g man he let me curse in
the in the
uh in the operating room and i remember
i was just cursing out because he
wouldn't let me sleep i go just let me
sleep i want to go to sleep he goes we
got to keep you up kid
so i started cursing he goes go ahead
call me whatever you want say whatever
word you want
and i kept cursing calling them all
kinds and they kept laughing
but uh yeah i still remember his name he
saved my leg he goes i'm going to try
and save your leg without putting any
rods in there because you're
i was 15. yeah you get on hand goes i
don't know what yeah and he did it
he did it deal you have you had any
surgeries besides that hair transplant
uh i love surgery um
but i can't believe you had three months
at 15 years old yeah you were
in the hospital you see those little
bars theo the the bars with all the
little bolts and [ __ ] they had to build
you got to remember this is 1984 so
advancement was like it's not like it is
now so they
built like this structure they had
maintenance build this structure
and uh they drilled a hole through my
shin
and put a pin through it and then they
clamped the ends of the
the the rod and pulled it with weights
so they build like this traction pulley
system
on this little housing thing that they
did and literally pulled my legs
straight
god who's your doctor just dr wigs i
know but he said if we if we do this we
can
we don't have to worry about uh a rod he
goes i really want to like
you know pull the leg straight and let
it grow together slowly
that's what happens damn what do you
have to i bet you have to get an
erection with a damn pulley now yeah i
jerked off i tripped off so many times
you can't let them win bro you can't let
them win no couldn't let them win
um i would like to say uh
what this guy ask us about surgeries oh
yeah i like surgery
i like it because you go there they care
about you they're nice they feed you
they put you to sleep they wake you up
it's almost like going through like a
child infancy again or childhood you
know it's like the
childhood you miss they come and check
on you every now and then
you know they're nice some of them's hot
someone's thick
they got all kind of people coming in
there and uh they give you meds they
make sure you're okay
can you read they take you for a walk
it's
i really i i i prefer it i hate it
i hate it oh i hate the hospitals at all
costs
yeah i hate them i hate them what was
the last surgery you had to go in
my nose oh really not like a cool
hollywood nose
yeah had uh merkel crow cops smashed it
with his elbow
so i had to have uh reconstructive
surgery on my nose
jesus how long did it take to heal up
quite some time that's a bad surgery
because they got to put these
like stints in there and they put uh
stitches to keep it straight until it
meshes and heals and then they get they
gotta cut it and yank those out
yeah oh terrible joe you ever rode a
motorcycle since
yeah i just got on one uh about two
months ago three months what
for the first time no i just wanted to
do it i just wanted to see if i
i still had it in me did you yeah but i
didn't want to
do what i used to do no you had too much
going on man yeah and is there a lot of
pressure in the
in the and i'm not i'm just going to go
out on a short bonsai
limb here and say is there a lot of
pressure in the asian community to do
tricks on motorcycles
uh i believe so we're just not allowed
to talk about it we don't say much
yeah i mean uh i might say the wrong
thing and commit suicide you know that
theo
i knew it let's see what this guy has to
say
my name is robbie i'm from stroud
england shout out to the pride is child
brendan
theo you look like a single butch
mother of three that likes to play rugby
in her spare time
if you've ever been in a group chat in
the uk with your mates
the chances are you've probably been
bullied at some point
so king it will sting it offensive
friendly banter
gang gang i like that
butt nugs that's my mama's hometown
shroud
really born and raised i think any
er just to start off if you don't mind
no anyone that has a video
in the the frame shows that they're
wearing a soccer shirt
always from the uk good chance always
from the uk
they're balls deep in soccer yeah yeah
paul's he's got a chevrolet logo on his
chest
make a decision man dude who wears a
shirt while they take a dump first of
all what pervert
right are you one of those guys that you
go
you go naked though dude what freaking
west essex pediaphile wears a [ __ ]
shirt while they take a poop man so you
take everything off theo
i i'll take mo i take everything off
that i can if there's a place to set a
shirt bro or hang on the doorknob i will
even if i'm at starbucks or something
it's insane
that's cool man yeah that is not cool
that's it so so you're you you you
really think you're outside
like an animal when you [ __ ]
i just i can't [ __ ] well if there's
things like holding my body back
you know i don't want anything
constricting my blood flow i want to be
able to [ __ ] [ __ ] like a king dude
like kamaru usman
[Laughter]
sure you know sure
and that that g-star uh hoodie is
restrictive
all of it is man anything that's like
this stops me up in here i want to be
able to [ __ ] put my arms up if i
really need leverage on this thing i
[ __ ] [ __ ] like a g
dog not like one of you little hoes bro
yeah yeah sure
it sounds like you're giving birth yeah
it doesn't sound like you're taking a
[ __ ] yeah go see a doctor yeah
well i don't poop every day like a lot
of people i poop probably three times a
week
what i poop i light about three times a
day
oh my god i'm not even making that up
you're getting after it huh what are you
a machine
gun yeah man my toilet
hates me my toilet's like you again
you do work i [ __ ] it up bro
that's crazy i i don't like doing that i
like to let it get let it get compact
and let it [ __ ] and then you actually
are
serving legitimate poop i'm not out here
just [ __ ] you know uh
soft serving every afternoon like some
[ __ ] little wait so you're
building it so you know you have to [ __ ]
on tuesday but you purposely hold it off
till wednesday is that what you're
saying you only have to [ __ ] for about
15 minutes then it goes away dude i
don't give in to the first sign of
pressure
he like he likes he likes to challenge
himself okay i don't
so it's a game for you it's a mental
game for theo
it's just like i don't know i find that
the whole thing works better for my body
it's my
my body knows it doesn't have the easy
way out all the time yeah show that show
that [ __ ] who's boss am i right yes
i mean something like that i mean that's
an easy way to say it but yes
did we even answer that guy's question
oh he's saying group chats like you and
your buddies roasting each other
yeah i guess several of those it's
fantastic
here's darren till got off the roads
right here let's see what he's got to
say
[Laughter]
what's up brennan theo cat chin
uh dick i uh
have a king enter stinging
taking baths as a man
i am 32 years old
i it's been about five years
honestly since i'm taking a bath um
i shower when i bought my house
i it came with a you know pretty big one
of those jacuzzi
bathtubs it's about
six and a half feet long i
am six one so you know
trying to take a bath when you're that
you know
baths as a grown ass man
gang gang buzz bug baby where's the time
for a bath
get a hot tub daddy yeah come on now
yeah
boom hot tub hot tub i'm bath you just
sit in your own
i hate it when you clean your [ __ ] in
the bath and then you dunk your head to
wash your head
yeah what the [ __ ] are you doing that's
called that
touch bro you got to do it you got to
write a passage bro
so you're you're into baths i mean
i think if you got to take a bath i'd do
like a seasonal bath you know around the
holidays thanksgiving when i got a
little
extra time or something i'll bath out
not a bath guy i'm not a bath guy you
know i don't mind that i just i think
it's
when i was young the heat didn't bother
me as much i'd be in there you'd be in
there three four hours you know and
drinking water i'd drink as much as i
could pee it out
drink more you know you'd be in there
two or three hours just learning about
how your body works
but as an adult the thing i notice as an
adult the heat
really gets me the heat of the water if
it's too hot gets me
well yeah that's a good point theo yeah
man
don't you stank her now it's the heat
yeah how do you think about
i i thought it was the [ __ ]
dingleberry that's the dirty water
that's
against me man uh not so much the heat
just the things that were in my butthole
floating in the water now
and those are the loose hairs from my
thigh and balls
yeah the hot filters all that [ __ ] out
you got the jet
yeah if you're ever wondering if a bath
is bad
as an adult when you drain the water
look at the sides of your tub
that was floating in the water correct
into your mouth
bro those are just lost villagers on the
uh on the ocean of uncertainty dog
you gotta [ __ ] stay in there and ride
it out yeah if you drink that water
jesus christ your immune system is
in incredible oh yeah if you had if you
had half a gallon of your own warm bath
water dog
oh it's for hoes bro i feel
sick what else you got nick uh a couple
more debate clubs and then we'll close
it out
uh this is tiny's tacos tv returning uh
oh they're the best man bro did they
ever send in some more tacos for us
dude my team uh can't find them they
they i they damned them on instagram and
then we never heard back
we got max holloway on this friday you
[ __ ] up tiny tacos is that tiny let's
talk
tacos tvs uh we we have their email
maybe they didn't see that last episode
because that was patreon only so they'll
definitely see this
uh get in touch with us reach out again
i'll do a recording
what up we're back [ __ ] your boy leo
h2o i'm tiny we got
another debate club for you oh yeah so
today
we're making a specialty taco for a
possible serial killer
and uh only fans royalty
on the red corner you've got that
crimson chin
taco it's a korean barbecue taco
inspired by chen himself
the serial killer it's beef bulgogi
pickled carrot and daikon drizzled with
that sanjan
hopefully i'm saying it correctly chin
will correct me or kill me
yes and on the blue corner we got that
only cats
only fans only taco only on only fans
that hook inspired by a vietnamese dish
and i asked two japanese co-workers
and they said i said it pretty good
i think i'll be all right yeah i think
you're good so from that we got
beef lemongrass garlic oyster sauce
fish sauce thai chilies brown pepper
lime juice and then we're going to top
that bad boy off
with pickled cucumber onion carrot
and then we're going to have a little
dip dip with the naocham
which is a garlic sugar lime fish sauce
green onion
and chili dipping sauce with some
vinegar you know what i'm saying
praise god sprinkle that with something
herbs
sprinkle that on my dick fam that [ __ ]
is tight
put that down to the hatchet all
in a handmade tortilla
so let us know the crimson chin taco
or that only cat's only fans taco only
on only fans
i'm going to say before we even start
there's only one way to find out i think
we got to get these bad boys to bring
some in
you know what i'm saying because just
from the looks around go that richard
ramirez taco that yeah killer taco looks
fantastic yeah i'm going to go with the
korean barbecue of myself
that was amazing the cat's only fans
available only on only fans
looks decent but yeah that richard
ramirez is fantastic
that was beautiful i like that hoof meat
bro i like that hoof meat on that only
fans feet only
feet first only fans but the cat's only
fans only available on only fans taco
cat needs to step on your tacos
yeah i want it to be foot closed i
wanted to be close
with that hook you know she's going to
be on uh she's going to be on first we
feet coming up
[Laughter]
that was an easy joke
uh one more but look man i'd say look
let's bring these freaking bring them in
yeah bring them up beautiful latinos in
and then get through
these killers in the studio and let's
yeah let's eat them on let's see
let's get the food on and judge in
person and then yeah get them on food
truck b
yeah i will man damn don't slip on our
[ __ ] mexican friends bro
two weeks they're going to be in here
brendan theo
debate club for you jackie chan movies
first jet league movies
which were your favorite who's better
also
theo you live in nashville that's only
four hours from st louis
come up our comedy clubs are open gang
gang
awful comedy clubs but yeah go up there
uh
what's your favorite of them have you
been to the one yo
have you been to the one in the basement
there the st louis funny bone were you
this they allowed cigarette smoke oh i
think i've been to that one
i'm not i'm not going to say that i
don't want to say the name of it but the
one i went the one i was at
uh they painted their logo on the wall
do you oh you know what i'm talking
about
and joey diaz warned me several times
not to go there and i didn't listen to
him and i went
and then after he goes i told you
[ __ ]
it was a nightmare bro they used to have
this one club there
and uh and thanks for the call brother
and thanks for the invite um
where the f it sat about 2 25 i bet
but the first two shows or the or the
late two shows were smokey you could
smoke indoors
and it was low ceilings like seven foot
and after about
20 minutes you couldn't see past the
first row it was just
full smoke fog style man
yeah that [ __ ] was illegal since like
1980.
she's still smoking doors some of that
midwest don't [ __ ] around yeah they
don't get them [ __ ] out there man
yeah you ready to die who's ready to die
uh i don't really [ __ ] with jet li to
answer this question i'm not a huge
jet league fan well he killed his dad on
accident
gently did what i think so didn't he in
that movie remember
oh in the movie oh damn it theo you got
to start that off like yeah
no on the movie set bro he killed his
father who oh
really you're thinking of bruce lee
brandon he got shot on the
set of crow on accident well look man
lizzy come leezy go bro one of these
[ __ ] shot the other one
okay somebody at least put
killer by him one of why he killed the
other one dog
yeah hey you know what jet li has two
movies that i know of i can't name a
jetley movie
i can name two lethal weapon four and
uh romeo must die must die i
do because jackie chan you got rumble in
the bronx
yeah you got the movies with chris
tucker yes which are great yeah there's
like three of those did you really see
the movies with
chris tucker yeah it's chris tucker's
movie what you know the name of the
movie well i don't
it's rush hour rush hour are you kidding
me right now
yeah sorry dude okay yeah especially
brendan if you're going to dress like a
rush hour fan every day
you know the [ __ ] really know the
name of the movie
and then he did rush hour with owen
wilson it was called shanghai nights
oh no yeah it was like the exact same
thing
what was it called shanghai nights they
were like that's right
yeah yeah that was a good movie yeah
yeah
yeah um what else did uh
jackie lee uh jackie lee
sorry what else did jackie lee do what
jackie lee
[ __ ] i'm off the waitress at that place
who are you talking about
theo you can't talk you said lee lee
jason leave
pptt what the [ __ ] are you talking about
the only thing yeah but i don't
know at least finds an honest mistake
yours is just racist yeah yours is like
hey looks like you're back at the kid
rock party yeah you said jordan right
after you went steven jackson was the
best
president he was my president
he was our president cheek lead
truncally
bunkerly who gives a [ __ ] stephen
jackson the president
jackie chan all day jackie chan all day
rumble in the bronx
great movie fantastic i love the rush
hours but
you no one will forget uh well i guess
obviously you guys
genuinely will gently lethal weapon four
was amazing he was good and he carried
yeah he didn't talk but i hear you
didn't talk yeah god
he didn't talk though you know he didn't
talk at all yeah he didn't say a single
word
not one [ __ ] word just rotated beads
in his hands
yeah someone got close you'd strangle
with the bees that's true but
jackie chan did talk and we still didn't
understand
yeah at least he's trying though you
know man it's true
what about bobby lee bobby
that's amazing bobby lee is amazing
i will go with bobby lee yeah if i pick
out of the three
bobby lee is the best uh kung fighter
movie star
agree uh ever why hasn't bobby lee done
a kung fu movie i wanted dude
that would be amazing probably because
the the the call time's
not 1 pm in the afternoon and also
you also need to know kung fu yeah
yeah it was kind of two two no no yeah
the fact that there's a call time at all
yeah doesn't matter what time it is
did you know jet li and bobby lee are
related though i just found that out
it's the crazy [ __ ] no way yeah i found
out uh
what did we find out chen
it's only it's within the asian
community there's a new letter yeah we
get a newsletter
it's actually it's an actual newsletter
that's in a scroll
scroll and someone hands it to you and
then someone else reads it
that's cool yeah it's pretty cool the
truth comes out
the the tiger belly producer george
kimmel live next door as a child
to uh muhammad ali uh and muhammad ali
would come over and read him the quran
and stuff it's like it's like the
craziest story
he grew up rich though yeah yeah that's
cool
wow very rich huh really cool yeah
so that's the thing that's all we got
that was mr joe coy
that was fun fun right i had a fun show
man i wish theo was here
me too yeah you know he wants to live in
nashville
live in nashville [ __ ] training i'll
be living back there as soon as it's
open
it's just not dude we're not listening
new sims getting recalled baby
and we're the restaurants open up next
week 25 capacity
you know yeah comedy store la jolla is
opening up this hit me up
we open it is it doug y'all still got
them hot state taxes going though
yeah man you what you pay for you get
what you pay for how's the [ __ ]
snow out there and the one club to get
up every weekend yeah how's that
street you get to visit every now and
then for uh entertainment yeah
how's the one road that you can go to to
eat a steak yeah
how's those bars all located in one
place yeah
filled with white people listening to
country music how's that yeah how
sharing each other's pie holes
[Laughter]
how are those bicycles that chicks ride
to drink yeah
those are the worst yeah all the
bachelorette parties
you know oh yeah
there's a lot of definite no's in the
area i think
um i will say this the best pb
and uh what was it it was a pbr
and a bolognese a fried bologna sandwich
was at a bar
in uh nashville and i went there all
week while i was at the uh what's the
name of that club
zanny's zanies i was at zany's i went to
that bar every night listen the best
thing in nashville is the moonshine
cherries
if you want to get [ __ ] up off about
three cherries and shine cherries
and cherries bam you ever had moonshine
mr bond i had it when i was young yeah i
had something that [ __ ]
one of my buddies had [ __ ] his eyes up
yeah that's that hooch that ain't
moonshine
this [ __ ] [ __ ] his eyes up dude but he
could he could blow start a damn
pressure washer though i will give him
that
so
well is that it that's it i'm in tampa
next weekend
next friday saturday tampa florida then
after that i'm
in cleveland hilarity's march 11. oh
that's such a good
i know nick the owner of cleveland
hilarities march 11th through 13th
i'm back-to-back to back weekends and
then i'm in spokane washington
spoken he said spoken by the way spokane
yeah for my b day oh is it
march 18th that's a good club too that's
spokane
yeah they don't break down too yeah yeah
those guys my hometown tacoma
comedy club they own that that's your
hometown club
yep wow good people my mama's moving up
there i forgot to tell you that tacoma
right outside tacoma wow wow i just
dropped your name what's that festival
they have every year don't they have
like a
do they have like a dandelion festival
up there every year what is that
they don't have much in tacoma
that's why i'm tripping that your mom
decided to move there yeah i know
because i couldn't wait to get the
[ __ ] out it's it's rough
no but it's different uh wigby island oh
whippy island
that's different that's beautiful yeah i
don't know yeah i don't know the [ __ ]
area
yeah she's gonna have a good time yeah
so we'll see
well i will be um
where will i be i will be i'll be in the
studio next week
nice miss you buddy get out of it i got
a book coming out march
23rd oh [ __ ] no way yeah
got a book coming out we already sold
out of the uh pre-signed copies we're
gonna do more
so you have one on audible for deal yep
we got that for you
uh uh read by uh
ray liotta
wow i heard those are a nightmare they
are i heard it's a lot of work it took
me two weeks to read that that's what i
heard
and i didn't realize how bad i was at
reading but god damn yeah
what was hard about it joe coy i'm
curious about that what was hard about
what was hard about reading the uh
for an audiobook one you gotta act out
you know like the quotes and stuff and
you have to keep doing it like line
after line right like yeah i've heard
so many people go dude the book was the
easy part the audible doing the actual
audible brendan we'll find out if we
just let him answer we'll find out
we're asking i'm just telling you we're
talking business and books here so maybe
take a hike huh
once you go playing this okay no baby
i'm trying to as soon as we get out of
this episode i'm just trying to find out
what is the [ __ ]
hard part about doing an audio book from
somebody who wrote an
audio book yeah you got to read you got
to read it perfectly
like you can't read it the way like when
you read you skip words and both
you got to read it word for word you got
to land those punctuations correctly
the quotes you like to do it in a
character you want to sound like it's an
actual
quote you know what i mean so a lot of
that
it was oh how to do it yourself right oh
i did it myself yeah some people have
other people do it it's just not as good
yeah i think they do it because it's
like a stunt throat yeah and
another thing was reliving those stories
you know it got emotional so
like there's a lot of things that i
talked about my childhood with my
brother and his his
drug addiction and it was just it was
hard what was his drug of choice
uh well you know he all you know my
brother he's like
he's still in him he's he's he's still
in the hospital to this day oh wow
so uh yeah it was it was a pretty it was
rough that's tough
reliving that and reading it out loud
you know so that that was hard
it was kind of emotional it was a roller
coaster in that in that booth
sounds good though man oh thank you man
it's pretty cool i
i can't get it it's in barnes and noble
like let's go
let's dope man that's awesome i love you
theo awesome man
love you too man i love you guys thank
you see you next week buddy
all right man i'll see you next week man
this little podcast king cause he got
ratted sting cause he fought back
theo got that hit a grey black bag shot
like a wrestle even though he never rock
mask
and you know cats gonna take your breath
lucky she got nine lives cause she fresh
to death
and i hope i don't come off strong i'll
make you log off when i'm in the dm's
and i send another hot dog
just kidding didn't send that pic that
would be too premature
just like nick i'm slick i'm sick too
legit to quit
they be calling me chappelle cause i got
the trick and tell me how am i supposed
to live without chin singing he gonna
take you on a date and just do a lot of
drinking ain't no thing
chicken wing is the bat with the rings
and the beat who can swing
it's the king and listening no kidding
[Music]
i think you'd be surprised i really do
years ago they tried uh one second years
ago
years ago they tried to tell me you
don't got the stripes webby now they
call me conor mcgregor cause i got a
tiger belly
heavy cheeto cause my rock is ready when
it's time to rock call the bird to get
his chopper ready nello browse palm
sweaty probably vomit mom spaghetti in
this state of mind always try to keep it
balanced so i'm younger than the lea but
my soul is old as cowan yo brandon
looking like he live with 16
kittens and theo looking like he yells
for when fishing
tight no foes don't matter god bless me
like i
got bad allergies this boy might just
burn white rabbits like dick boy bike
club burn those calories
no kidding yo you better listen king and
the stink killing in the opposition
bumble and mouse to be in the credit
gang gang buzz buzz go
oh
[Music]
here we go
oh
wow